Hi, my name is Bushger, and today we are going
to talk about information theory. Now, information theory is not
really a machine learning algorithm, so we'll, kind of, first
understand why we need to learn information theory. Usually, you
could teach a whole course on information theory, but for
now, it is sufficient to know the basics. So first
we'll try to understand where information theory is used in
motion learning. So consider this to be any machine learning algorithm.
For example, let this learner be, or a decision learner,
now we have several inputs, x1, x2, x3, and one
output. For simplification, let's assume that this is a regression
problem. That's why we have one output. We want to
ask interesting questions like how is x1 related to y,
x2 related to y, x3 related to y. Why do
you want to ask such questions? If you remember, from
our IDT algorithm, the first step is to find out which
input best splits our output. So we need to find out which of these, x1, x2,
or x3 gives you the most information about
why. So we have to first understand what the
word information in information theory means. In general
every input vector and output vector, in the
machine learning context, can be considered as a
probability density function. So, information theory is a mathematical
framework which allows us to compare these density
functions, so that we can ask interesting questions
like are these input vectors similar? If they're
not similar, then how different they are? And so
on. We call this measure as mutual information.
Or we could ask if this feature has any
information at all. So we'll call this measure
entropy. So we are going to find out what
these terms mean, how they're related to information learning in
general, and we'll briefly look at the history of this field.